de dos sur cette photo du journal de
saône et loire le garçon qui s'est
rendue ce matin au commissariat de
chalon on voulait le rencontrer pour
qu'il apporte la preuve de ce qu'il
avançait pour avoir des éléments
tangibles
ils étaient près de rencontrer
d'ailleurs ce matin avant d'aller au
concert vendredi après s'être fait
remettre la caisse de la grande
pharmacie verte chalon l'adolescent
avait une fois de plus revendiqué son
acte par un mail à la rédaction du jsl
par mail toujours le journal décide
alors de poursuivre le dialogue avec lui
on a échangé durant le week-end avec lui
pour savoir qui se cache derrière ces
mystérieux mail depuis des mois échanger
pour avoir une épreuve de vérité pour
savoir si ce qu'il avançait était vrai
et on a fait une demande d'interview
qu'il a déclinée puisqu'il disait dès ce
week-end dimanche être en rapport avec
le procureur de république de chalon
pour sa reddition
ce matin lundi au commissariat de chalon
ce matin avant de se rendre
l'adolescent accepte d'être photographié
de dos et de parler à la journaliste
marion jose il n'y a jamais eu de
commandos au marteau lui dit il
j'ai tout inventé et j'ai toujours agi
seul
maintenant j'en ai marre de tout ce
cirque le jeune homme de 17 ans est en
garde à vue à chalon